- Tom Angel says this.
"Neil, do you agree with Carl
Sagan and most US voters that"
- Yes.
Yes, next.
(audience and Chuck laugh)
- Hey Tom, there's your answer, Tom.
There's your answer.
- Yeah, there's very
little I disagree with.
- And guess what, I'm gonna
go ahead and say that,
but quite frankly
- No, now we gotta know.
I wanna know.
- Now you wanna know?
- Yes.
- "...That marijuana should be legalized."
- Oh. (laughing)
- [Both] Whoa!
- Yeah.
- Whoa.
So, I think if you really analyze it
relative to other things that are legal,
there's no reason for it to ever to have
been made illegal in the system of laws.
- That is extremely rational,
which I expect from you,
and you're absolutely right.
- I mean, alcohol is legal and it can mess
you up way more than smoking a few jays.
- That's absolute.
- Yeah, so.
- Boy, let me tell you something.
I can tell you have never
smoked weed in your life.
(audience laughs)
'Cause you just like,
"smoking a few jays."
(audience laughs)
It was like a ABC after-school special.
(Neil laughs)
- Are you smoking a few jays there?
(audience laughter)
- The last time I was
like in a cloud of it,
that's how people spoke, so yeah.
- Okay, right on.
Okay.
Alright, let's do one
quick one because you
- Oh, by the way, by the way,
it's just funny because if you
wanna sound like Mickey Mouse,
you inhale the helium
from a helium balloon.
- Okay.
- But the way you do that
is you untie the knot
and you go
(sucking in air)
(laughing)
like you're sharing one, it's just.
It's just, it's so
- Right exactly, in other words,
when kids are at a party,
sharing helium balloons,
they might as well be smoking some jays.
(audience and Chuck laughs)